que llegaréis significa para aviso en
lengua de origen y es el primer nombre
que tuvo la isla fraser este lugar es
único es la isla de arena más grande del
mundo ubicada frente a la costa oriental
de australia
fraser es una isla arenosa de 122
kilómetros de longitud en las
inmediaciones de sus orillas se hallan
vestigios de grandes bosques fluviales
que crecen en la arena así como la mitad
de los lagos de una elevados del planeta
con agua dulce sus grandes bosques en
los que hay árboles con más de mil años
sus lagos y el complejo sistema de dunas
de arena que el viento mueve a lo largo
del año y alcanzan hasta 240 metros de
altura la han clasificado como
patrimonio de la humanidad por la unesco
poblada apenas por 182 personas cada año
miles de turistas son atraídos por este
lugar las playas tienen arena blanca y
el agua es cristalina todos sus sitios
naturales son de una excepcional belleza
con vistas al océano pacifico y en las
rutas migratorias de las ballenas
pero el fuego ha destruido más de 74.000
hectáreas la vegetación de la isla
fraser es extremadamente seca por lo que
las llamas se han extendido tan
fácilmente las autoridades y los
bomberos continúan trabajando para
apagar los incendios que desde hace seis
semanas tienen en jaque a este paraíso
ya sus habitantes